hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
fourth of februari and I don't blame you
at all for not keeping up with those New
Year's resolutions I like ice cream
better than working out too first off
the mark today our GSP's of yesterday
hit just as that watch dogs story was
concerned to be done by a prankster so
let's get stuck into that turned out the
request for abandonment of the main
watch dogs trademark was filed and
forged by a prankster who apparently did
a pretty good job since he fooled
everybody that Ubisoft and probably yves
guillermo who was said to have
proclaimed that's not my signature
probably he probably said that who you
be have said they're working to get the
trademark green stated and a reassuring
game is that watch dogs is still one
hundred percent on the cards do you guys
think this prankster is in for a
significant dose of legal action or is
it the last we'll hear of it in gender
have yet another strategy to help pick
themselves off the pavement this year
and who knows it just might work
president satoru iwata has said he's not
ruling out the possibility of company
mergers and acquisitions to make a
profit this year a water admitted this
kind of move would be very unlikely
entender but the way things are going a
little outside of the box thinking would
probably not be a bad thing for the
publisher a water was also asked if a
Nintendo based theme park could be a
viable revenue raiser to which he
replied they'll consider their options
but didn't seem totally on board with
the brilliant idea is there a company
you'd like to see Nintendo birds with or
are you just holding out for a real-life
Nintendo land in 2017 our absolute
favorite craps Terra christofer sundberg
has roiled everybody up again this week
by saying that Triple A games are
unprofitable and unhealthy the Just
Cause dev says that the games industry
is sorely in need of evolution since
currently publishers are nervous because
they have to think about games projects
that might be successful way in the
future and devs are frustrated because
they have to be flood
able to publish your wins Sundberg says
Triple A games rarely bear a profit
which probably hits him a little close
to home so the executive is currently
working on a triple a title himself Mad
Max whether you love her or hate her
Morgan is back with what one can assume
is a vengeance in dragon age inquisition
images hi rose detailed pics of the
character and her costume are the first
from what will be a series of dragon age
character guides from bioware in the
hope that they'll help fan artists
cosplayers and cake decorators the image
in question shows the non-playable
morgan in a ball gown with close-ups of
all her finery so those who are so
inclined can labor over getting her
necklace and course it's just right let
me know which Bioware character you
would most like to cosplay either in
that comment it down below or you can do
so on my Twitter where I'm accessed
McDonald that's it for me today but be
sure and let me know what your favorite
stories have been and if you would be so
kind to check back with me for more news
tomorrow